Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
¿Cómo Adolf Hitler, un tirano
que orquestó uno de los genocidios
más grandes de la historia humana,
llegó al poder en un país democrático?
La historia empieza al final
de la Primera Guerra Mundial.
Con el avance exitoso aliado en 1918,
Alemania se dio cuenta de que
la guerra no se podía ganar
y firmó un armisticio
poniendo fin a los combates.
Conforme su propio gobierno
imperial se derrumbaba,
los disturbios y las huelgas obreras
se extendían por todo el país.
Ante el temor de una
revolución comunista,
los principales partidos se unieron
para reprimir los levantamientos,
estableciendo la República de Weimar.
Una de las primeras tareas
del nuevo gobierno
fue la aplicación del tratado de paz
impuesto por los aliados.
Además de perder más de un décimo de
su territorio y desmantelar su ejército,
Alemania aceptó la responsabilidad plena
por la guerra y pagó las reparaciones,
debilitando así su ya alicaída economía.
Esto fue visto como una humillación
por muchos nacionalistas y veteranos.
Creían erróneamente que la guerra
se podría haber ganado
si políticos y manifestantes
no hubiesen traicionado al ejército.
Para Hitler estos puntos de vista
se volvieron una obsesión,
y su fanatismo y delirios paranoides
le llevaron a culpar a los judíos.
Sus palabras encontraron eco en una
sociedad con muchas personas antisemitas.
En ese momento, cientos
de miles de judíos
se habían integrado
a la sociedad alemana,
pero muchos alemanes siguieron
percibiéndolos como extraños.
Tras la Primera Guerra Mundial, el éxito
judío generó acusaciones infundadas
de subversión y proliferación
de la guerra.
Es necesario insistir en que
estas teorías conspirativas
surgen por miedo,
enojo,
e intolerancia,
no por un hecho.
No obstante, Hitler tuvo éxito con ellas.
Cuando se sumó a un pequeño
partido político nacionalista,
su discurso público manipulador
lo catapultó al liderazgo
y atrajo a una multitud
cada vez más grande.
Combinando antisemitismo
con resentimiento populista,
los nazis denunciaron tanto
al comunismo como al capitalismo
como conspiraciones judías globales
para destruir a Alemania.
En un principio,
el partido nazi no era popular.
Tras un intento fallido
por derrocar al gobierno,
el partido fue prohibido,
y Hitler encarcelado por traición.
Pero tras su liberación
cerca de un año más tarde,
de inmediato empezó a reconstruir
el movimiento.
Y luego, en 1929,
ocurre la Gran Depresión.
Esto llevó a los bancos estadounidenses
a retirar sus préstamos de Alemania,
y la ya aquejada economía alemana
colapsó de la noche a la mañana.
Hitler aprovechó la ira de la gente,
ofreciéndoles chivos
expiatorios convenientes
y la promesa de recuperar
la antigua grandeza de Alemania.
Los principales partidos eran
incapaces de manejar la crisis
y la oposición de izquierda estaba
muy fragmentada por disputas internas.
Algunas personas frustradas
apoyaron a los nazis,
aumentando sus votos parlamentarios de
menos de 3 % a más del 18 % en 2 años.
En 1932 Hitler se postuló
para presidente, perdiendo
la elección con el héroe de guerra
condecorado, general von Hindenburg.
Con el 36 % de los votos, Hitler
demostró el alcance de su apoyo.
Al año siguiente, los asesores
y líderes de negocios
convencieron a Hindenburg de nombrar
a Hitler como canciller,
esperando canalizar su popularidad
para sus propios objetivos.
Aunque el canciller era solo
el jefe administrativo del parlamento,
Hitler expandió constantemente
el poder de su mandato.
Mientras sus partidarios
formaron grupos paramilitares
y combatieron manifestantes
en las calles.
Hitler generó temor por
un levantamiento comunista
y argumentó que solo él podría
restaurar la ley y el orden.
Luego, en 1933,
un joven trabajador fue culpado
de incendiar la sede del Parlamento.
Hitler aprovechó el evento
para convencer al gobierno
de que le concedieran
poderes de emergencia.
En cuestión de meses
se abolió la libertad de prensa,
otras partidos fueron disueltos,
y se aprobaron leyes antijudías.
Se detuvo y ejecutó a muchos de los
primeros partidarios radicales de Hitler
junto con sus rivales potenciales,
y cuando el presidente Hindenburg
murió en agosto de 1934,
estaba claro que no habría
nuevas elecciones.
Es preocupante, las primeras medidas de
Hitler no requirieron represión masiva.
Sus discursos explotaban
el miedo y la ira de la gente
para impulsar su apoyo
y el del partido nazi.
Mientras, hombres
de negocios e intelectuales,
que querían ubicarse en el lugar
correcto de la opinión pública,
respaldaron a Hitler.
Se aseguraron reciprocamente
de que su retórica más extrema
fuese parte del espectáculo.
Décadas más tarde, el ascenso de
Hitler sigue siendo una advertencia
de la fragilidad de las instituciones
democráticas ante una multitud enardecida
y un líder ávido de alimentar su ira
y explotar sus miedos.